und bist du dann verona in diesem ton
studios in hamburg natürlich auch dieter
bohlen dann über den weg gelaufen oder
wo waren sie erst als die karriere
beendet war
da hatte ich ja praktisch täter kennen
gelernt weil manche denken hätte mich
produziert oder unter stimmen wenn die
das ist alles davor gewesen und zu dem
zeitpunkt hatte ich auch diese fünf
internationale schönheits titel und mein
atelier man immer schön die sei
natürlich hier in hamburg eine
rutschbahn und dann kamen die teils er
war auch nicht der beginn meiner
karriere war so mittendrin der uhr
knallt ist nichts
ja das kann man kann man also irgendwas
können das musst du in ihm ausgelöst
haben hat sich ein hat sich irgendwie
schock verliebt ja und du beschreibst
das auch so und er war einfach ständig
da hat auch konferenzen dann einfach
abgebrochen wenn du am telefon war sogar
ohne hat angerufen die muss jetzt
dringend nach hamburg fahren
das heißt was war das für ein etwas war
das für eine situation ja also ich habe
ja immer ein buch geschrieben das ein
toller mensch ist und das hat mir
gefallen hat sonst hätte ich nicht
geheiratet die er mit seinen drei
kindern damals umgehen wie viel zeit das
ich für alles genommen hat und auch
diesen mut zu sagen ich heirate dich
jetzt einfach auch ohne ehevertrag auch
wenn diese geschichte schon lange
bekannt dass ich mein der macht das in
seiner situation
wer geht mit mir ein jahr aus ohne was
mit mir zu haben wir haben ja nicht mal
gemeinsam in einem hotel zimmer
übernachtet wir waren ja immer nur im
auto im restaurant weil wir gar kein
paar waren aber wir trafen uns 365 tage
und dann habe ich ja gesagt in andere
auch geheiratet also es ist eine
liebesgeschichte mit höhen und tiefen
mittendrin gab es auch mal nicht so eine
schöne situation aber klar eine zeitung
kann nur kurze ausschnitte mission
klandt in meinem buch beschreibt aber
auch dass er auch ein toller mensch
am anfang war und dass ich jetzt am
anfang auch wirklich mich ja ja ja das
ist doch in ordnung da hatte man muss
ich habe mein leben mit diesem satz ich
war meinte wolf doch gottes willen aber
ich hab mir nach vier wochen erkannt
wenn es schon nicht mehr abschneiden ich
hab ja noch vier wochen die scheidung
eingereicht schneller kann ja nicht weg
[Applaus]
diese diese hochzeit wie kam es zu
dieser hochzeit nach las vegas spontan
ich das gerne nach vorn sie haben also
ganz kurzfristig geheiratet in las vegas
und vier wochen später haben sie gesagt
sie möchten sich wieder trennen ja und
was also dass es so was war denn das
spiel und davor waren sie 365 tage
verliert platonisch sei und nur in
diesen vier wochen spielte sich etwas ab
und danach haben da waren sie
verheiratet und haben sie gesagt jetzt
ist schluss und warum machen sie das
also ich habe ich schreibe ich auch
wirklich vom herzen gleichen
entwicklungen das wo ich hab noch alles
dabei
vielleicht erzählt ist ganz kurz
wir haben uns auseinandergelebt in dem
vier wochen
[Applaus]
wirklich schade da hätten sie darauf
das ist hier sehr gut ja also habt euch
auseinandergelebt ja und es gab dann den
denn es gab diese diese frage also du
lagst irgendwann verletzt im krankenhaus
wurde medial auch alles ausgeschlachtet
wir wollen das foto auch jetzt nicht
noch mal raus holen mit einem bösen und
genäht und es ging um die und der
vorwurf stand im raum für sie als
strafverteidiger interessant dass dieter
bohlen sie möglicherweise geschlagen hat
oder nicht so und dann kriegt das muss
ich ja sie ist so schon sagen er hat
sich dafür entschuldigt in der sendung
gehen man kann sich nur entschuldigen
für das was passiert ist aber es ist
nochmals ist 22 jahre her
es ist ein alter hut und manche fragen
mich natürlich auch wie kommst du jetzt
wieder auf die geschichte aber ich habe
ja meine biografie schreibt dann gehört
die geschichte ja das kapitel in meinem
buch ich doch nicht und es ist ja nur
einer davon
und das endet hier auch kein ich mit
lieben worten ich will nur sagen eine
eine autobiografie besteht immer darin
dass man verrückt ähnlich von seiner
vergangenheit erzählt bis zum heutigen
tag
und dann habe ich halt in 20 kapiteln in
1 gewidmet und es ist ganz okay das sind
nur die reißerischen schlagzeilen
manchmal und die leute denken das ist
der punkt
es macht es macht es ist ja auch ein
ernstzunehmendes thema also gewalt in
einer beziehung ist ein ernstzunehmendes
thema und deswegen bewegt das dann auch
viele menschen und rüttelt die natürlich
auch auf und wenn das einer
selbstbewussten frau passiert und dass
auf diese art und weise eskalieren kann
dann ist ja die botschaft für uns alle
daraus dass wir alle niemals so wirklich
sicher sein können dass uns nicht
irgendwann mal was ist nun nicht gewusst
so genau
und deswegen haben das auch gerne noch
mal erklärt eine andere szene die
untrennbare die können es kennen sie
möglicherweise mit rot-rot verbundenes
ist die auseinandersetzung mit alice
schwarzer ja die war mindestens genauso
spannend ist es denn dazu gekommen war
oder ich jetzt auch im nachgang habe ich
mich das oft gefragt also dieses
aufeinandertreffen bei johannes da was
bei johannes b kerner im studio wie war
das gedacht bevor wir gleich einen
kleinen ausschnitt daraus sehen war das
gedacht als sozusagen netter kleiner
schlagabtausch treffen sich zwei
interessante frauen wie sie
unterschiedlicher eigentlich nicht sein
könnten die aber ein war
doch eine menge gemeinsam haben oder war
es von vornherein etwas so klar war
heute abend gibt es ein bisschen krawall
und warum eigentlich nicht also frau
schwarzer war einfach plötzlich aus dem
nichts auf einer buchmesse mit ihrem
heft emma unterm arm und stand vor
journalisten und sagte plötzlich haben
wir unser feldbusch ist eine ohrfeige
für jede deutsche emanzipierte frau so
und dann habe ich das dann genie
mitbekommen recht auf dieser buchmesse
war und dass sie hatte in der presse
langsam durch mein manager hat er mich
jetzt seit 30 jahren begleitet er
richtig an und sagte du ruhn habe bis
eingeladen von johannes b kerner die
frau schwarzer und touren duett und dann
hab' ich soviel zeit muss man schwestern
im geiste wir treffen uns hier schon
dann sagt der nähe ist wie immer
ausreden lassen was ist denn überhaupt
wert ist und ich sehr witzig ja
frauenrechtlerin genau
und dann sagte er ja aber die ist jetzt
kein kein fan von dir dies kann nicht so
begeistert von dir so etwas muss
missverständnis sein da sagt der nächste
es kein missverständnis sondern dann
zitiert er diesen satz sich die ohrfeige
für jede deutsche man zitierte frau bin
habe ich großes missverständnis weil ich
lebe so extrem emanzipiert in einem land
wo ich übrigens auch die chance hat man
immer wir deutschen frauen betonen dass
oft so und ich muss auch sagen andere
haben gar nicht so die chance wie wir
aber ihr habt die chance und ich lebe
auch so und bin denn zur sendung
gekommen und habe dann damit gerechnet
dass eigentlich ein nettes gespräch
entsteht ja aber vor schwarzer sei das
wirklich ganz schwarz die war ganz ganz
anders zu mir und ich hab bin denn auch
wohlerzogen sie ist ja das ist nicht
böse gemeint dass dieser mindestens drei
jahre älter ich habs jetzt mal ausreden
lassen weil ich dachte ja nun lasst sie
erst mal ausreden aber nach denen die
brille schon geschlagen war und sie mir
erzählen dass ich verantwortlich bin für
alle magersüchtigen kleinen mädchen die
ständig bei ihr klingeln und sagen sagen
sie dieser bewohner feldbusch das wird
mir ganz furchtbar wie die aussieht
wecken könne denn da zu hause und nicht
okay und dann kam eine sache nach der
anderen
wir haben mal ganz erst wurde schwarz
und schwarz also muss man wirklich
schauen wir haben mal ganz kurz ein
bisschen zeitreise sozusagen wir gehen
zurück in das jahr 2000 18
ja ich habe sie ja nie kritisiert sie
sind hier aufgetreten und haben gesagt
wir ohne feldbusch oder nur selber
spielt sie auch freundin ist eine
ohrfeige
das ist eine ganz andere sache die
darstellen
und jetzt aber ich habe schon deutlich
ja und was sind eine ohrfeige ein uriges
definitiv eine äußerung die aussaat
schmerzhaft unangenehm damit meine ich
das was sie da stellt nicht nur und ich
werde jetzt versuchen darstellt das bin
ich also ich stehe ja auch was da das
sind sie doch ein hohn alle wissen
lassen sie doch vorher die daumen dass
sie das doch auch da war demnach mehr
und emanzipieren das frauenbild das sie
darstellen das ist das freiwillig
das als der werbung ist ich lebe so wie
ich lebe aber wenn ich morgens geduscht
bin gebe ich glaab zumal mit
sommersprossen und keine wenn man
täusche aber wo soll denn das große
geheimnis sein wenn man diese hose sieht
das bin ich und wenn man das sieht das
bin ich morgens abends mit der java und
die haare sind auch recht also dass
billy
sie sind begeistert ja ja ja ich fand
das interessant dass wir das heute noch
einmal gesehen haben die reihenfolge
also die hose dann hier und dann hier
auf dem haupte sollen sie hatte davor
einige sätze dieselben stark geäußert
dass ich nur dass ich künstlich wäre und
dass das hat mir alles futsch ist und
dass ich so sieht tat so als wäre ich
nicht echten also man kann sich in
lüttich drauf machen können sie auch in
bern aufgeben aber letztendlich wollte
ich damit in der sekunde nur sagen ich
bin doch die person die ich hier stehen
abgesehen haben sie auch wenn dann
tuschen haarsträhnen und noch eine kette
um daraufhin sagte sie nein und das
beste war die johannes b kerner zitierte
den spiegel
da stand braydon trifft body und ich
wollte den kleinen spaß am anfang machen
und dann sagt ich wusste gleich dass wir
so gut in shape sie haben super body
nein nein nein das verstehen sie falsch
und ich würde auch das war doch nur spaß
und ich erwarten meint sie ich bin brain
so gibt es denn die ersten zehn minuten
und am ende meiner jungs noch
geschrieben punkte sieglos und sie hatte
definitiv keine fenster
[Applaus]
die szene von schira ich mag das sehr
gerne
also ich finde wenn man ihn länger
anschluss gibt es eine ähnlichkeit zu
franjo finde ich ein bisschen weiter
aber in paris gehören ich bin jetzt so
etwas vollkommen richtig und man kann
auch sehr gut aussehen und emanzipierter
zahlen was zu möglichen orten machen das
schon alles ganz gut so
ganz kurz seid ihr da seid ihr euch
eigentlich hinterher noch mal begegnet
gab es da jemals eine aussprache weil
man das ganze ist ja an die schwarzen
die alte schanze aufzubrechen
alice schwarzer ist hier auch jemand der
einen tollen humor hat und die ich auch
über alle maße schätz massen schätze
also das ist ja jemand der mit dem man
wirklich auch spaß haben kann warum ist
und dass dann muss so es kann ja man
kann nicht einfach so sachen auf markus
aber gut humor und spaß weil sie da
stehst du glaub ich sehr alleine da man
kann ja ich habe ja auch komplimente
gemacht ich habe gesagt 68 haben sie für
die frauenrechte gekämpft
wenn ich noch mit schnuller um
weihnachtsbaum gelaufen wir sind aus
verschiedenen zeiten und ich kann ja was
es schon gibt sehr viele gemeinsamkeiten
zwischen ich frage das deswegen auch
vielleicht lagen durch einfach mal
zusammen ein
es gab tatsächlich würdest du das machen
ja hier zu sein studio zu ja damals
johannes b kerner k s wurden am nächsten
tag von der bild zeitung die worte
gezählt und dann kam raus dass johannes
nur drei sätze sagen konnte und ich weiß
noch wie er sagte jetzt muss ich noch
was sagen und ich denke dass mit um
ausreden und er hat im grunde nur drei
sitze in der sendung gesagt und man
wollte eine revanche einläuten
aber sie kamen nicht es ist eine tat war
sie wollte nicht aber wir bekamen einen
anruf von der regierung dass wir beide
zusammen auf einem plakat fotografiert
werden sollten
irgendwie wir für arbeitsplätze stehen
sie rechts mit ihrem heft emma und ich
links damals war ich
vorstandsvorsitzender streams ag und
habe in 118 filialen von karstadt meine
die bademode und meine
das waren bademode ach ja und
sportsachen vertrieben also 118
milliarden für das nur betonen damit man
versteht das war ernst zu nehmen und war
der vorstandsvorsitzende und dann hat
man uns auf dieses bild eingeladen
da das ein anruf von der regierung waren
wir beide zugestimmt jetzt mussten wir
ja beide in ein studio für der fotos ja
das war spannend ich war da ich war
damals schwanger ich habe meine produkte
mitgebracht wie ausgemacht das wurde
alles ganz genau überprüft und sie ihre
und kaum standen wir da ich hatte ein
schwarzes kleid mit dem bäuchlein und
hielt meine produkte siehe f vivendi
dass da so hält er mache ich hier kein
foto und ich die da das sind bestimmt
ich meine verkürzt indem frau schwarzer
ist mir die soße der hand verkauft
dessous bademode und sportwäsche dann
meine ich dann sie verkommen da auch
emma heft abgebrochen wieder alle weg
wieder alle das bild wieder zurück
wieder dahin wieder zurück und zum
schlüssel ist das bild dann entstanden
aber es war sehr sehr kompliziert mit
frau schwarzer sehr und sie war auch
damals lange in der maske wenn ich das
noch hinten
[Applaus]
ich bleibe trotzdem dabei ich finde an
die schwarza toll genauso wie ich dich
sehr sehr mag also das ist nein das
müssen wir missverständnis irgendwie
seien davon bin ich immer noch überzeugt
zwischen euch beiden
vielleicht kriegen wir das noch mal hin
ich habe gerne von mir aus wirklich
gerne
ich möchte frau schwarzer ich jetzt
nicht ein buch von mir noch schicken
daher kriege ich das zurück was uns
nicht zu weit gehen gleich haben
eigentlich denke ich schreibe nicht
schlecht über sie das kann man so nicht
sagen ich habe zum schluss gefragt du
hast schreibst an einer stelle ich habe
mein ganzes leben lang eigentlich um
anerkennung gekämpft hast du heute das
gefühl dass du angekommen ist
naja anerkennung vielleicht nicht
sondern in dem sinne dass die
gesellschaft mich anerkennt weil mein
hohes selbstbewusstsein hat ja dann
irgendwie platz gelassen für keine
anerkennung ich fühlte mich immer
anerkannt sondern mehr worum ich
gekämpft habe ist eigentlich ich liebe
ist eigentlich dinge die mich
herausfordert anzunehmen und mich dafür
so ich sag das mal so glaubt gerade zu
machen und diese anerkennung aus dieser
situation ob es sich auch meinen job
bezieht aber sich auf ein gespräch
bezieht oder eben auch auf ein projekt
wo man es an zweifel dass ich die
richtige bin ist ganz einfach ich kann
nicht alles aber das was ich zur sache
ist wohl überlegt und dann weiß ich im
vorfeld schon dass ich das kann diese
zeit der nichtanerkennung die
entspannend und da kämpfe ich darum um
hinterher ansatz sagen es hat doch
geklappt so ist immer wieder neuer
produzieren diese momente die mich und
suche anerkennung aber nicht von der
gesellschaft
das genügt wenn die mich
durchschnittlich nett finden oder
sympathisch aber ich kann ja nicht zu
jedem hause und den überzeugen dass sich
ein netter mensch bin und ich will ja
geliebt von meiner familie um mehr kann
ich auch gar nicht so verlangen wenn die
leute noch netzen und sagen auch ein
schönes buch oder schön sie zu treffen
dann ist es einfach auch schön dann ein
prominenter zu sein also manche
prominente haben so schwierige position
von polit politik angefangen bis auch
andere situationen wo sie denn wirklich
vom volk nicht so gemocht werden dann
ist das leben nicht so einfach aber
solchen schmunzelt still vor sich hin
ich habe jetzt mal eine halbe stelle
versteht sich
hier sehr heißen sehr sehr laut
auch gerne was weiteres mal sprechen ja
machen wir irgendwann über bei mir
gibt's nicht viel
das finden wir noch so